welcome to the Tim Dylan show everybody
it is Tim Dylan I want to start off on a
serious note I want to address something
that a lot of people are talking about
and it is it is about race and it is
about changing our society and it's
about holding people accountable and
that's something that I've become more
open to in the past week you know
holding people accountable I don't I
don't think I've been really excited and
I think that is the right word by the
amount of people who are outing
themselves as problematic and I've been
I've been excited by it because I think
that's the first step to really healing
and creating an equitable Society the
first step is for people to come out
Jenny slate comedian writer the show big
mouth Jenny slate is a white woman and
she played the role of a character named
Missy on big mouth an animated show on
Netflix and Missy was a mixed-race
character who had a Jewish white mother
like slate and a black father I mean
clearly we're looking at Missy here
Missy is clearly black even though she's
mixed-race but you know Jenny slate has
recused herself from the show and she's
leaving because she said black
characters should be played by black
people I don't think that's enough okay
she's contributed to the erasure of
black people SH and she's said that she
said she erased the black Prarie I don't
even know what that is
I don't know what futuristic weapon what
ray gun she used to erase a black person
but I don't think it's enough to just
say sorry and go back to your mansion no
thank you ma'am Jenny slate has to go to
jail she has to be brought up on charges
and she has to go to jail for no less
than 10 years for what she did this is
not a [ __ ] joke stop laughing you
white Pig she needs to hear every night
she needs to hear the bars clink she
needs to lose her freedom what has she
done with her freedom she's used to
erase black people by voicing the
character a mixed-race character on big
mouth on Netflix no thang and cancel big
mouth while we're at it sorry Nick Kroll
cancel big mouth you're gonna have to
get a job with your family doing
security related matters I'm sorry I
don't I don't want to be this way
but I am I don't want to be this way but
I am Jenny said I've come to the
decision today that I can no longer play
the character of Missy on the animated
TV show big mouth at the start of the
show I reasoned with myself that it was
permissible to play Missy because her
mom is Jewish and white as am i but
Missy is also black and black characters
on an animated show should be played by
black people I acknowledge how my
original reasoning was flawed that it
existed as an example of white privilege
and an unjust allowances made within a
system of societal white supremacy and
that me playing Missy was
gauging in an act of a ratio of black
people bud and jail now put her in jail
put her in jail why is she not in jail
why are the producers of this show not
behind bars goddamn them goddamn her I
am NOT I'm only laughing now because I'm
so angry that when I laugh I get out I
get I get angry and I laugh but I got
damn than blacklivesmatter
do you understand that they matter on
the Netflix cartoon put her in jail that
Nick crawls parents bill not even the
rod not even a touch I mean an
underground prison what do we not know
what they do use Google dummies I get it
she's got to go to jail a secret
underground facility where she can be
re-educated not my fault I want to hold
people accountable they're being held
accountable this week that's it no more
games this week tim is here to hold
everyone accountable well I apologize
for the bit I did with Nick Mullen where
we said that Orthodox Jews were wearing
diapers to to landlord-tenant court
because they were pretending to be
insane so they could continue to rip off
their minority tenants I will not
apologize for that that I will not do
because I did not erase a black person
in that if anything I called attention
to inequality with that you see the
difference I've had enough for too long
I've sat on the sidelines while
cartoonists have destroyed the fabric of
American society
we cannot tolerate this anymore most
importantly though Jenny says to anyone
that I've hurt I am so very sorry oh I
bet that feels good I am so very sorry
how many people have killed themselves
because of this how many lives have
ended because of your show I bet it's
unquantifiable how many people killed
themselves put a gun in their mouth
jumped off the building cut their own
throat maybe their wrists od'd on pills
took a hair dryer and electrocuted
himself in the top it's fix eiated
themself hung them sir I bet all of
these black people that are dying
tragically with nooses and they are
hanging themselves because they found
out that Missy was voiced by Jenny slate
that is that is a hypothesis I have it
is not proven it is a hypothesis but I
think it's pretty damn good so I'm I'm
I'm asking Miss slate ms slate and the
any producers of big mouths to turn
themselves in to the military not even
the LAPD those corrupt bastards no the
military to be to have a tribunal and we
need a military tribunal in this case
and they will not have a jury of their
peers they will be tried by a jury of
people that are selected the people that
have been affected the people that have
been affected failed comedians will
judge her comedians that don't make any
money will judge mislaid people that
have podcasts that have 45 reviews on
Apple will stand the judgement of Miss
slate mr. crawle and the entire show
they will judge you and I hope they
explain it to them explain it to the
people that couldn't even get a [ __ ]
free drink
for their horrible comedy and have
wasted their entire lives those are the
people you have to convince and the
death penalty is not off the table I'm
not saying it's gonna be I'm not baby
it is a tool it should be available to
the prosecution that's what I'm saying
here I'm done letting people off this by
the way what I'm doing here is what
everyone's gonna have to do this is the
new strategy with woke people is to go
more woke than they are this is the new
strategy like when they say we should
take down that monument you go we should
nuke an American city that's what you
say if someone says now I want to get
rid of this monument go let's nuke DC
let's nuke Washington you got it you got
because you got it a got a look at you
like huh like it's it's gotta be so bad
now like when they say when she steps
out a big mouth I go we shouldn't have a
big mouth it's got to go it's tainted
it's over it's over that's what you're
gonna have to do you're just gonna have
to when somebody says to you when
somebody starts a conversation goes
listen why not get rid of all these
monuments go I owned I will do you one
better
I will do you one better why not get rid
of them all at once let's nuke
Washington DC let's get a suitcase
nuclear weapon and and and and nuke
Washington DC and if they if they're
shocked by that or they argue against
that you just look at them ago laughs oh
so you're gonna you're gonna take the
monuments that are offensive and leave
the White House and Congress and the
Washington Monument and what no no no no
we are going to nuke the Capitol that is
the woke position and when things get
bad and then and when things get better
when the radiation is gone in a few
months or years I don't know then we
will go and build an equitable Society
but we're not we're not going to do
these surgical strikes we're not going
to do these surgical strikes we're going
in with a suitcase nuke we're going in
with a suitcase nuke and Jenny slate
will be publicly executed for what she
has done to the black community yes or
yes yes or yes don't get that as the
great Terrell Davis drunk
real estate motivational speaker in Long
Island would say yes or yes don't give
them don't give them the chance to say
no should these people go to jail for
their own
tweets yes or yes yes they should I
don't even know who these people are but
they're trillionaires Shane Dawson
jeffree star they've got their own
literal planets they own literal planets
Jeffrey star on Saturn and you're trying
to cancel him he owns the planet Saturn
which date date I don't know what
they're doing they're painting it with
face paint you've made an entire
industry of people that only talk about
makeup what the [ __ ]
people in makeup used to not have public
personas because they didn't need it who
is that chick from Maybelline nobody
knew she was Rita Revlon whoever the
[ __ ] these Rita nobody cared
people knew Coco Chanel was that was it
but like it's cosmetics what is so
important about makeup
can someone illuminate this sick trend
for me please can someone help me
understand why people painting their
face like Harlequin clowns in their in
their room that is only lit by the blue
light of their computer and they sit
there and they put makeup on their face
and stare at reddit threads can someone
explain to me how this makes eight
trillion dollars a week they have more
money these people and you you can't
cancel them they own the earth they own
the earth on which you live your Twitter
doesn't matter I think Shane Dodson to
rate he owns the earth I don't know how
it happened I don't know how it happened
that the only thing that's buy
profitable in this country anymore is
makeup that's the only industry we've
got left is people putting lipstick on I
I miss that somehow that trend missed me
but apparently one of them though the
Geoffrey star the one that looks like I
mean let's be very honest if you'd
bumped into Geoffrey star in real life
you would go what I mean your first
thought wouldn't be this is a beauty
consultant let's be very honest about it
is no shade to him or whatever I don't
even know anymore
there'd rich dude on that you don't get
a gender when you're a trillionaire
you don't get a gender anymore you're a
planet but if I bumped in the Jeffrey
star it would be like interesting that
they made their money with cosmetics and
no shade to them good for him
whatever good good God love you I'm just
confused as always I exist in a
permanent state of confusion on this
program I don't understand
I look at people out they all look like
[ __ ] no one's even wearing the makeup so
I guess people just wearing it in their
[ __ ] hovels they live it are they
eating the maker is it edible known as
food nobody has any money or food how
are they swinging $100 makeup cats who's
buying us fat women in the Rust Belt are
sitting there put men women who ever
who's doing this I thought everybody's
money went to opioids how do they have
the money to get going to make up now
but you can't cancel them they own you
stop trying to kill I don't know why
they're gonna canceling them Shane
Dawson did blackface and one of the
photos he looks like Oprah's weird he's
a chubby gentleman in Egypt blackface
that's why I don't do blackface I don't
need people calling me precious
hashtag precious what's people of a
certain amount of money it's like you
know what are you canceling does it
matter but they will have to pay too
they will have to also go to the into
the military tribunal of which they will
own they will buy their way out but they
must they must I think every star called
someone fat once he must hit he must
have town he must atone for that he must
atone for calling someone fat it is not
right not right he must be brought up on
charges for that and Shane Dawson did
blackface you know what's funny about
the blackface
I wonder when blackface was acceptable
cuz I like I got in a comedy in late
2010 early 2011 I would like never to
black that like I'm wondering when that
when people thought that was okay like
didn't know
think this is maybe not a good idea I
understand like in the early 2000s or
whatever but when anything like I don't
remember when that was like a thing that
felt like a smart move like let me just
do blackface I'm sure this you got to
think to yourself if you're if you've
make yourself up in blackface it
eventually this might come back to her
yeah I think a smart person has to think
think like when they're when they're
putting on the makeup and they go you
know what this is like I say we're doing
characters right I mean that's the
argument right they were doing a
character they like makeup that's what
they're into that's how they made all
their money you can't just pull white
makeup on it gets boring occasionally
you got a throw on a little copper a
little tone right I don't know I'm
asking I'm asking these questions
because I I truly don't know the answers
when I was a little kid I was an actor
we know this I'm a [ __ ] star when I
was a child I was in South Pacific
it is a Broadway show about Polynesians
me and my little cousin Katie who was a
white chick I'm clearly white we put
like bronze makeup on and they gave us
Asian eyes don't make a face what are
you making a face for was the [ __ ]
90s
what if Polynesians done for you happy
birthday by the way it was his birthday
the other day and I don't care because
birth celebrating birthdays are for
their achievements for people that don't
achieve people are never more entitled
and disgusting than on their birthday
cut it out when you're 18 birthdays and
they end enough celebrate
accomplishments not that you've survived
another year so happy go [ __ ] yourself
and we I was made up to look like an
Asian and given a black wig and the
audience loved it it was me and my
little cousin and I forget what song we
were like happy talkie
happy talkie talk now it wasn't a
problem back then because we were they
Polynesians and maybe there weren't
Polynesians that wanted to perform in
the [ __ ] Bethpage high school you
know South Pacific performance maybe
there weren't just lines of Asians I was
displacing by being a young kid in a
[ __ ] community theater production of
South Pacific I mean I don't know I'm
trying to look back on some of my
problematic race behavior in terms of
putting makeup on that was probably the
I erased the Polynesian child with that
move I should tweet that I should go
when I was a child I was in South
Pacific it was a community theatre
production in Long Island I was given a
black wig and orange paint and they made
my eyes Asian and I sang an Asian song
and I pretended to be Asian come for me
[ __ ] I mean that's the truth and I'm
I'm ashamed I did that and I will kill
myself after this program okay because
I'm deeply shamed Texas is shutting down
again I hope you enjoyed your
rattlesnake bites get up the rattlesnake
bite is a very nasty appetizer the
rattlesnake bite oh it's a medical
emergency
it is a medical emergency but it's also
so the rattlesnake bite is an appetizer
what is it then it's a jalapeno popper
cream cheese wrapped in bacon and baked
yeah or grilled and the rattlesnake bite
is is pretty is it Texas thing right
totally yeah well I hope you've enjoyed
them Texas is shutting down again
they're shutting back down Florida
shutting back down here's the deal
I live in LA for now and I Drive around
and I see all these children and young
adults and and and and people of all
ages really but specifically on the
younger side standing outside of these
stores and I want to know what they're
waiting for they're all in the line and
call height beasts rake hump had his
phone stolen by a hi Beast one day he
was in an uber pool and a kid like a
supreme sweatshirt swiped or he comes
phone and then he had to go to like the
cops and he was like he was reporting
his phone stolen I don't know why it was
just he had to do it for to his
insurance whatever claim I don't know
and he's like my phone was tagging my
hybrid hybrid circuit but the beasts are
they love t-shirts and sneakers and [ __ ]
like that
[ __ ] dot-com online store sells out this
[ __ ] sells out June 27th from June 26 to
tip typically items sell out in a matter
of minutes after we open this toward
noon on certain Fridays why don't you
subscribe to the newsletter of [ __ ] comm
follow on IG or Twitter start mentally
preparing a strategizing on how to cop
items while everyone else is in FOMO
frenzy made and getting carjacked by
supposed BOTS I'm amazed at these people
are fans of my show but they are and
that's great this is what we want we
want to expand the base you know so this
is great you got to look cool unless you
like I don't have to look cool because
I'm like talented but you're not so get
cool [ __ ] that's how you get laid that's
why people will talk to you be that you
know white guys now you're just kind of
have to be like good-looking and quiet
and cool that's the only that you just
kind of to stand there not really say
anything if anyone says anything just
say black lives matter and move on on
about your day and the way to do that is
in a [ __ ] shirt [ __ ] pop-up god shut
down by the police Wow
that's how much people care about [ __ ]
at the pop-up we shut down by the police
it was LAPD huh went in there just did
they shoot anybody
do they show restraint um there's gonna
be no promo codes no free shipping no
discounts no free [ __ ] it's knocking
none that none of these gonna be free
because this has a high resale value
okay this is a game that the high peace
play they play it very well they buy
this [ __ ] they resell it get in the game
get smart this is online life now this
is digital currency got a really get a
[ __ ] you got a [ __ ] hat on yeah they
sent me this and the jacket yeah great
they are and I got a sweatshirt too I'm
not wearing it but I might um it came
with a high based hype the open the box
the high B's kits out it's vaping yeah
you know
do you want your branded Wardell they
sent they open it you open the box
brandon waddell yeah I guess give me
that I really want to die go to [ __ ]
calm if you see t.com so call to action
this is real deal [ __ ] okay like this is
serious [ __ ] I know you're like oh it's
just t-shirts it's it's not it's this is
how people make a living now this is how
people look at the Manufacturing's over
the industrial base of the country's
over you're gonna have to buy and sell
shirts you should subscribe to the
newsletter how do they do that I think
at the website at the website you
subscribe to the newsletter and then we
could see what the founder Mark Burnett
II things right what's he think let's go
to him Eric Brunetti it's easy can you
go back
the [ __ ] thing please Jesus
easy-to-read of-the-moment short and
concise interview with Eric Bice store
in Malaysia easy to read well it better
be
it better be I don't know if worn piece
is the demo I'm very happy that they're
advertising on the show it's you know I
am a very much into fashion and everyone
knows that and I'm I cannot say enough
about the culture of shirts and sneakers
and the people that buy these and resell
them I think they're the greatest
Patriots to have ever drawn breath in
this great land I think it's so
important to stand on a line or
digitally wait on a line for shirts and
and you can buy them and resell them
it's very important I'm thrilled about
this and you like your clothing Ryan I
love this stuff well why do you keep
zipping it up do you think people don't
know how to use a zipper you keep
showing you showing it off by zipping it
up this you know what it reminds you
have a corn heart
I remember corn heart yeah Carhartt car
heart whatever I don't wear it I'm not a
pig I'm not a [ __ ] I'll work on a
[ __ ] the Long Island Railroad what
are we doing I hope this I hope they're
paying thirty thousand dollars for this
I really do a fire everyone in my whole
[ __ ] team is getting fired by the way
hope everybody's ready for that firing
everyone except my realtor in the desert
it's the only [ __ ] person I like go
to [ __ ] calm WWF uh QCT calm I mean
listen this is it is fun to [ __ ] around
with this ship I shirt resell it use
your promo code is not promo code right
yeah there's nothing you don't get this
is I
this is high-end go to Tiffany's what do
you think you're gonna get a promo code
for - no hi and they sent me a big
sweatshirt get that I'll put it on I'll
see if I like it
Ben could have you know prepared before
the show but that's you know that's not
his MO it's not what he does he's too
busy golfing
it's alright give it to me it's blue and
it has the word [ __ ] hmm comfy
yes cotton it's made it
I had a friend from Honduras I grew up
with him Rolando 50% cotton 50%
polyester thank you I appreciate that
thank you I ever listening to this over
there the Sinaloa cartel or will whoever
is enjoying this thank you so much I
truly you know there's a lot of people
out here that are into fashion and at
least into the business of buying and
selling things online and it's well
worth it for them it does look cool I
mean I'm for that I'm for going to a you
know place where there's a cartel and
putting clothes on them I guess I I
think that's cool
I think cartels are cool I really do and
I think that people should have clothing
lines that glamorize you know
potentially negative behavior the
Sinaloa cartel cares like more about
their people than like our government
cares about us it's kind of true you
know what are you gonna do
I mean that by the way and this it
here's the reality and the Sinaloa
cartel like probably doesn't care that
much about their people but it's still
better than you know follow on Instagram
or Twitter what are they [ __ ] f you
see T on IG or Twitter that's important
to you want to be part of the culture
they didn't give me a link for what am I
like that it's too late to recycle I
want that one can I have that oh is that
a shirt yeah it's kind of cool I like
that and then there's bin Laden well I
like some of this now yeah some of the
[ __ ] some of it is actually good that's
been bad that's is that a bin Laden
scarf yeah I what can I have that why
don't I have that well I think it's
limited what is this blue [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna walk around the Cookie Monster
where's the [ __ ] bin Laden scarf what
are we doing or dead rooster from the
the sinaloa video always send me the
bird will - yeah I'm gonna walk around
and look like a blue M&M in this [ __ ]
thing where's the bin Laden scarf or
that let's not recycle it [ __ ] it all
sure it I like that
I want that bin Laden scarf and I want
it now what about those two aliens
what's that one well this stuff is
already sold so I know this is the stuff
that I can't get cuz it's [ __ ] elite
that's pretty cool yeah but that's what
I want [ __ ] like that but I don't get it
I guess they send that who - who Brendan
Schaub I get to [ __ ] into Cookie Monster
sweatshirt and he's in a [ __ ] he's in
a [ __ ] he looks like a cop it's gonna
get his head caved in [ __ ] calm fu CT
calm if you get the stuff you could
comment on IG and brag about what they
were able to purchase if you get it or
what you missed out on a lot of kids
making money reselling [ __ ] because of
high resale value is this a UH
is this an ad we got because they
dropped off you know who's podcast
something's not right
right something feels off here [ __ ]
dot-com suc t-dot-com
go to it and get involved with fashion
people ask me where are you on masks
people say to me they're like where are
you on the great mask debate of 2020
here's what I'll say folks as if person
who's 300 pounds and spent the majority
of life drinking and doing cocaine
I don't comment on public health policy
I just don't do it now many comedians do
many celebrities - they might be 7000
pounds and drug addicts they may eat
their own vomit they may be bulimic and
anorexic or anything but they still
comment on public health policy because
they think people want to hear that from
them they think people want to hear from
them how to be healthy in the middle of
injecting things into every area of
their body I say if you
if I go in a store I wear a mask and let
me tell you why I wear a mask I don't
know [ __ ] about the transmission of
coronavirus I wear a mask is everybody
else is wearing a mask
okay it's the same reason I wear shoes
when I go into a store it's because
they're required when I'm outside when
I'm alone when I'm in my car wherever I
am I do not wear a mask I don't go
inside restaurants I don't go inside
bars because coronavirus I do believe is
real and I don't want to get it so I
stay on patios and I stay away from
other people other than people I know I
kind of did that before the pandemic I
wasn't just diving into groups of a
hundred people so I don't really have a
strong feeling on this but just be
prepared for them to reverse what they
said about masks because they've
reversed a lot of other things about
this I'm not saying they will or not I'm
just saying just be ready for it and
stop you know it's this you know
battering ram that people are using
against each other yeah listen man if
you're inside somewhere it's probably a
good idea to wear a mask at the present
moment you don't have to I don't think
it should be a law that you should the
private businesses are allowed to to to
regulate their business the way they
want to and if they mandate that you
wear a mask you have to wear a mask if
you walk in without a mask and they've
asked you to wear a mask you're being a
dick you're just being a dick for no
reason in wherever shopping you know
supermarket you're going into you know
what makes me mad about the masks I was
in the desert and that's where I'm
spending a lot of time that go out to
the desert I go to the desert you know
I'm I am Tim Dylan the only comedian
left in LA I'm kidding and that's a
comedy we're a comedy show I go to the
desert now and while you let the left I
go to a comedy show I mean I don't go to
that I go to the dead buy these tickets
for these shows in August that I'm sure
will be canceled I'm kidding
buy the tickets I go to the desert and I
and you know we go to this Mexican
restaurant and it's outside and you have
to walk inside for like a brief minute
to get to your table outside okay you go
in and then the woman starts
with damask she goes you gotta have the
mask on I said listen I'm walking with
my two friends we're alone they're like
we gotta met wear a mask on all the
common areas of the restaurant I'm like
well I don't want to be in the common
area of the restaurant I want to walk to
my table so you're making me put on a
mask so that when I get to my table I
take the mask off what are we doing it's
five seconds to walk to the table I'll
have to put my mask on for what I
understand if I'm standing in a grocery
store or if I'm sitting inside of a
place but I'm literally walking through
to get to my table and the woman's like
you got to have your mask on and then if
you don't have your masters gotta go
like this this is my favorite thing
people just put their shirt above their
nose stop blaming the protests stop
blaming the early reopening we all
decided we all came together and said
we're done with this everyone's I want
to go back to work I need to go back to
work I need to throw a brick through the
window at a target I need to burn the
thing down and I get it because cops are
[ __ ] nuts and people want to get out
there some people want to do to
rattlesnake bite some people want to get
out there and [ __ ] you know attack
the government whatever it's fine
whatever you're doing is fine you just
want to be outside are you going to
Denny's are you burning it down it
doesn't matter you just want to get out
don't one side can't blame the other
side they have to unite fat people that
take cruises and violent anarchists have
to unite their fat people can wear
suicide vests that will pack so much
dynamite in them that they could take
out the entire House of Representatives
with one fart you understand
why should people go together let's stop
blaming everybody there's so much anger
in the country right now I don't know
what to do there's so much consternation
there's so much bitterness there's so
much division no leadership
there's no except here on this program
here but nowhere else is there any
leadership I've suggested what to do
military tribunals for every everybody
involved with big mouths everyone wears
have you heard that
where are your woke friends your woke
friends didn't say that have that I
think Sarah Cooper's talented she's a
pleasant woman and she does need the
Trump thing please stop calling her the
greatest political satirist of our time
please stop I like her and I think what
she's doing is fun but please let's not
get hysterical as we always do okay I'm
not mad at her I want her to have all
the opportunities sure I get it but
let's rein it in she would probably
agree with that okay
I know everyone loves her and no one
loves me and that's okay this town does
not love me they don't love me Jerry
Seinfeld does not love me
Patton Oswalt doesn't love me they don't
retweet me they don't care
they've taken no interest in me nor will
they and and I realize that's because of
my words and actions the reason that
these people don't [ __ ] with me is
because of my words and actions my
general demeanor my beliefs and my
unwillingness to compromise them for
whatever so I get it I'm not hating on
anyone I want everyone to do well but
it's just what it is and I have these
meetings with everyone and everyone's
like you should have your own show
here's the deal when I when I'm about to
have my own show I will be called into a
room or it'll be a zoom conference and
somebody an executive will say will you
apologize for when you and Louis Gomez
and Nick Mullen did Sebastian Maniscalco
goes to Africa bed where you basically
said and I quote let's let the Italians
cater the clitoris to me
will you apologize for that and I will
go no that is funny and they will go
yeah but now so that's why I won't have
a show it's not going to happen so I
won't apologize and then and then even
if I do so if I apologize and I look you
know and I and I go against everything I
believe then they give me one or two
seasons of a show and then I'm gonna
come back to this podcast and ask you
guys to [ __ ] you know like give a
[ __ ] about me after I've just
compromised it's just doesn't it's not
the way it works
I'd love a show I'd love them to let me
do a show or a movie but that's not what
it's gonna be they're just gonna give it
to people that lip-synch I miss what
Twitter is it's let you know everybody
meets without tick-tock everybody on
tick-tock and they go lip synch let they
don'ts nobody sings their songs nobody
writes songs I mean it's a it's a it's
it's very strange what's going on right
now it's very strange that people are
enjoying people lip-sync things other
people did not as a novelty as like
entertainment it's interesting but the
answer what the younger generation wants
they want to lip-sync they want they
want people that are good-looking it's
all about optics you know what a
good-looking person to lip-sync a song
it was great as if you go on tik-tok you
just see the white kids dancing trying
to not say the n-word that's the whole
challenge of tik-tok that's the
challenge of tik-tok you know white kid
you can't say the n-word they're like ah
they smile they just got a smile through
the n-bomb they just can't say it can't
say it Florida man Florida's like
they're just drowning in a sea Iran and
they don't give a [ __ ] and shout out the
Florida shoutout to the greatest state
that's ever been yeah I this is why I
love Florida I went to side's Pettersson
campus and I just [ __ ] on Tampa for 20
minutes and when I was done shooting on
it they seemed disappointed they they
know what it is down there they know
what it is
one of our greatest episodes brownie
bout on the patreon details my time in
Florida but I respite my friend
this kid Dan Carney who used to open for
me when the world existed he's gonna
come to LA for a little while he's down
to Florida right now and he said it's
just you know wild like it's just wild
down there it's just it's you know
there's people running around what is
that a bug a moth we're in like a carpet
in hell you know I mean can you imagine
loser you have to be to have an
apartment the carpet like why we have
carpets here you have to be [ __ ] if
you have a carpet but Dan was just
saying that he ran into some old lady
like he's picking up a pizza yeah and
yeah some old lady's sitting outside the
pizza place she's like it's just
fear-mongering from the military so like
I like
that like I say maybe I end up there do
I end up there those seem to be fun
people they don't have blue checkmarks
they're blue lips because they're
overdosing on oxycodone and that might
be my demo let's our Cooper if Hollywood
God lover I support it
she's a pretty she does an interesting
look to it's very she's very pretty
though she's like someone you want to
get to know she you see or anything I
want to get to know where I want to have
lunch with her I want to spend time with
her people see me that's not their
feeling they want me to tell them
something and then leave immediately you
know there are people like that we I've
had those characters populated my entire
life people that you want to say
something and then go away I tell us
something and then get out of here we
just had the old guy from from upstairs
wanted to look at the tile on the UH on
the deck on the whatever it is what is
that called it's just a balcony yeah
it's a balcony it's not a deck it's a
balcony uh and then the guy comes down
and he's like the building was built in
1947 and it's like yeah yeah he starts
to go into like the way the different
apartments were configured and he's been
here 50 years he's been here 50 years
you know then he starts doing this thing
my favorite thing is like why would I go
buy a condo for 1.3 million when I got
the space I need up there I'm like well
that's true and also you don't have the
money to do that you also don't have 1.3
million dollars that's part of the
reason why I'm gonna go buy a condo I
got all the space any year I was talking
to big Jays ex-wife who I love Carla fat
Carla I call her she's a plump woman as
a mine and she was telling me she had
coronavirus in Long Island she was
having like blood clots in her mouth I'm
like spitting out the blood she like
such a horrible bloody nose she's just
like spitting blood and she was like
standing outside of an urgent can she's
like open second I have another mask my
mask saw bloody so that's wrong that's
the way long guy has been handling
coronavirus just stroking out outside of
urgent cares spitting blood like
velociraptors she told me she goes she
goes my daughter was so happy the first
time she could have chipotle we both
started crying because the first time we
could eat
she just imagine that just chubby people
in Long Island in a Chipotle just crying
just crying into a burrito ball yeah I
mean Long Island is a I mean it's wild
God love I like her she's handling my
tickets I my license is suspended right
now the Long Island comedy club has
opened a comedy club in the alley of
their building governor's comedy club
which has banned me his opening uh they
have all I said was that the audience
was grotesque wearing sweat pants I said
they were wearing their starter jackets
on from the 90s and what do you want me
to do [ __ ] you want me to lie you want
me to tell them they're hot I didn't say
they were bad audience I said they were
grotesque it looked like you know I mean
you know the Hollywood improv the
audience is like hot influencers and
they suck after time yeah look how thick
I didn't think it's funny
I don't think it's funny I don't think
it's good where's the comedian from the
Netflix shop
but you know I'm bands at and I like him
we're having good we're gonna have to
Leon why not let's do it rough couple of
weeks
but not no one's been convicted that's
the reality I believe the rule of law
not really but I believe in due process
I believe you got to give people their
day in court I believe that yeah I have
no problem with him on a personal level
you know if he's done the things people
have said then then it's like no good I
understand that you know what I mean but
I mean I will have them on to plead his
case though he should do a bigger show
than this you know probably shouldn't
come on here probably low rent you know
he badge his team be like what show did
you do she - Rogan what do you do he's
like I did have a Tim Dylan show like
what what if we have Krista Leon next
week with Candice Owens what if what if
we did that and like he doesn't know
she's on yeah somehow I get cancelled
him and her start dating we're having
fun folks it's the end times you must
enjoy yourselves
Chris you're on the program with Candice
Owens you know Candice D'Elia defends
himself oh yeah with guest Candice Owens
what a fun episode I'm just trying to
figure out how to have fun I'm getting
bored I want to have a little fun let's
kick up a little dust like that girl Kat
Cohen was uh she's a talented comedian
she's a UH out of New York City she does
uh like um you know cabaret comedy and
she sings she tests what she does and
then she got she did a sketch and I
talked about this on the patreon she did
a sketch where she was satirizing white
racism or millennial entitlement
whatever and she put up one of her
friends a black guy in a news cuz one of
the bits was she's like my parents owned
slaves there's a black guy named news
and it came out like two weeks ago that
was like not the week right for that to
emerge but I just like I just thought it
would be funny if like she just went all
right cabaret she was like Bale the wall
build it now let's talk about the shapes
of skulls would it not be funny if she
did that yeah it would be funny why
can't we just admit that that would be
funny if she went to if she was in
neo-nazi yeah
cabaret there's enough gay people in the
alright that she could make a probably
pretty decent career at that yeah
culture matters so these gay guys the
audience who's on the path cat what
who's on the piano I don't know who can
play Phu Spencer who can play piano I
don't know I don't know which one of
those guys can play piano you have to
find it out culture matters Europeans
built our lands she's just like you know
but she galya galya quote right Nazis
yeah there'd be something there is what
I'm saying
where are the managers you can see this
I can see it it may not be a good idea
for Korea wouldn't be that it would be
short-lived if she became a Nazi cab
Iraq it would be short lived a short
window but strike while the iron is hot
get in there and give him a few hits get
a few hits and move on you know she'd
just come out like you know like uh
whatever you know like a sash you know
and she just sits on the thing she grabs
a microphone is somebody doing with
piano and she's like let's talk about
crime rates it's uncomfortable
and everybody's like swaying would be
hilarious so next week Chris Thalia
Candice sounds we got it we got to shake
it up a little bit here folks why not
have a little fun we're gonna be a war
with China in six months
how's that second slice of cake
break your keto diet it's it's coming
China's gonna come and I don't know I
hope this is not true but I've heard
I've heard this is what I've heard I've
heard that China the country of China
okay I've heard is behind a lot of
what's happening right now they're
behind it
from what happened - big mouth - up who
on The Simpsons
I heard trying to gave Hari Kondabolu
money and they pushed him to make the
documentary there's something wrong with
that poo right wasn't that the
documentary yeah I think that's it was
it who took a poo was it documentary
about a poo but I think China's behind
that documentary is very divisive the
problem with the poo is that what I said
I think so yeah oh I said something is
wrong with a book well the problem with
the poo I think China China is B this is
China's sewing division and this is how
they did it they made a documentary
about a beloved character on The
Simpsons named a poo it was a business
owner yeah he was an immigrant to
America he was beloved people liked him
but the problem of the poo was that he
owned business or who's he owned a
quickie Marty because people don't like
the idea that Indians or any race is
stereotyped
Irish people being drunk Italian people
being criminals now The Simpsons had had
the Italians were criminals the
gangsters right they had the the mayor
who's very creepy who's a Kennedy guy
that Homer who's the white American
buffoon the ultimate American idiot
right
they had Patty and Selma the whatever
spinster smoking potentially dykes we
don't know but they had a lot of these
characters who played in those
stereotypes but a poo is especially
distressing to Indian people I guess
because they were teased with the accent
yeah people would tease them with the
accent um and then and that was hurtful
to them when my grandfather was growing
up he was Irish and then there others
were people were Italian and they would
beat the [ __ ] out of each other with
like weapons on the streets of New York
City people aren't nice to each other
that isn't new we don't need a cartoon
to give kids the excuse to be cruel kids
are nasty and cruel and vicious and
vindictive ask Thalia that's a joke I'm
kidding and I'm I've done nothing but
help so I get it I was made fun of it as
a kid okay people always may in front of
me oh you're so cool you're so popular
he's so shallow you're fake you just you
just want to be with rich people I took
abuse people like oh yeah mr. [ __ ]
popular mr. Everybody Loves You mr. do
whatever you want
mr. hangs out with all the cool kids mr.
gets all the good drugs I took horrible
abuse as a child I would lay awake at
night oh you don't care about anybody
you're always with the cool people you
just always at the coolest parties I get
it I get it when someone comes at you
autumn doesn't care about his friends he
just likes to cool kids cuz they love
him everyone loves you that's what
people you say to me it was ready to
hurt when they go yeah everyone
loves you like literally everyone I
would hear that and I have to go home
and process that do you know how hard
that is to hear constantly that I'm
adored and loved and an iconic figure
that is hard so I get it if somebody
went up to you and good I get it and I'm
not for it I'm not for that I am against
doing that to people but I'm also
against creating a world where we're
because how many sacrifices will we have
to make as people to create a world
where and by the way this would be
impossible but the idea is that we could
create a world where the likelihood of
that happening is is not is is less by
taking away an Indian character who owns
a store and has an Indian accent Indian
people sound like that I like that
accent I like accents I like West
Indians I like it if I like that they
sound different who's the racist
I love Jackson Heights I like them and
they like me they love brown people love
a fat person they're the only ones that
do and you go in and you eat gulab jamun
it's like a pancake it's too shaped like
a small ball I used to going with
Raymond and they would bring us these
deep-fried things and they're in it they
they date date they fry them and like
there's a lot of diabetes there they fry
them in like some type of syrup and they
spit syrup glob jamun they spits here
and myself and Raymond you just go to
Jackson Heights and all the Indians
would come and share it not mouth like
that me go we're not rah rah rah rah rah
rah and and all of the pinions would
love us and many many of them would do a
traditional dance around us so this idea
that people shouldn't be different or be
stereotyped is stupid it's crazy it's
crazy I don't understand what's what's
the problem
with a guy that owns a kwik-e-mart he's
doing good yeah
well if not all on the Indians Oh quick
money of course they don't of course
some are comedians some are losers but
the ones that aren't I mean so Hank
Azaria played the Indian character a poo
in the Simpsons and he said he was
stepping down from the role following
years of controversy now that role by
the way do you know who's gonna play
that role now Jenny slate Jenny slate
will be doing it now and I saw and I
support them
what if Jenny slate see these people
were [ __ ] funny Jenny slate would
tweet I'm now going to be a poo I'm
gonna tweet that right now I'm gonna
tweet I'm gonna I'm gonna tweet very
happy than Hank Azaria step down that
Jenny slate will be voicing the role of
a parade we're trying to have fun I
don't understand I mean nobody can have
any fun anymore everything's outlawed
this is why people are out in the
streets have you heard of this new thing
they think the cop did de Blasio got rid
of that plane closed NYPD officers so
they think there's a conspiracy that the
block is there's a lot of fireworks
going on raised in Brooklyn he told me
that so there's a conspiracy that the
Blasio and the cops or whoever are just
giving fireworks to homeless people
letting them go crazy with them so that
it's an excuse because they just came up
with this new fireworks Commission which
will be undercover people so it's like
they took away the Undercovers but
they're like okay but where we this this
new groups gonna be undercover this is
what people don't understand they they
think abolish the police there's not
gonna be any law and order in the world
there's gotta be law and order and you
might like it less power vacuums are
gonna be filled you know this is the
result of people that go to college and
have no they have no [ __ ]
understanding of how the world works and
they think they can like shame to you
that doesn't work in real life go up to
somebody who realize me like I'm excuse
me I think that you're a bit like you
can't build people put a gun in your
face so punch him in the face they'll
put it and I'll cut your throat it
doesn't work your Twitter antics don't
work in real life not with criminals
now with
criminals people that want to kill you
don't really care if you can't go and
cancel people that want to kill you
that's not the way it works CAD salt
your cab fault
after fronting critically-acclaimed rock
band lionize who they are talented and
they're fans of the show of the past
decade for the past decade
Nate Bergman is making his first solo
music that's already being described by
classic rock magazine 'as Otis Redding
crossed with Bruce Springsteen and
making instantly likable Tunes that hold
their own metal hammer UK says Bergman
has one of the most original voices in
modern music and distorted sound
describes his first solo show in London
as a jaw-dropping performance American
press American songwriter says painfully
honest and witty lyrics that are
delivered through powerhouse vocals the
songs were recorded analogue and feature
real instruments which Nate played all
of himself Wow that's [ __ ] rare it
sounds very different from it sounds but
it sounds very different from dozy cat
if you love dosha cat you might not love
this
there's no songs about buts I mean who
wrote that did he write that probably
him I started beef with Dozier cat you
know however there are songs about allen
dulles and i'm being trolled by the ants
now I'm dead serious now are they are
the ads of troll this week because if
they are it's good but if they're not
everyone's getting fired there's songs
about allen dulles middle of the end is
about allen dulles and the life of the
American entertainer living on the line
Nate is a rough member of the patreon
and has been a fan and supporter for
many years well thank you Nate we don't
need to start a war with dozy cat we've
had a rough couple of weeks anyway you
could go to
on patreon.com slash Nate Bergman sings
for just $5 a month the patreon features
exclusive studio songs live streams and
playlists companions that are uploaded
everyone can we play some of what he's
done on this yeah let's find his stuff
right now
[Music]
dr. Livingstone
he's got a great voice but they're up
there it's coming out of the girl
[Music]
called the middle of the end go back to
that what is song about isn't that one
of the episodes in my podcast called
middle of the end cuz I said to rag or
the beginning at the end and Ray said it
where the middle yeah right where's my
money
this games mind that's the title of one
of my podcast do we have a lawyer who's
representing us skin nuts trying to
start with dosha cat and then saying you
gonna names he he's like you might like
my new song life in the big city right I
mean he has a good voice
he plays instruments we appreciate that
is he going out on his own now is he
done with lionize looks like he's solo
now what happened to lionize bands are
rough man can you go up
yeah I mean is this good he's got a lot
of great reviews people are into it
maybe he still would lionize I don't I
don't want to say he's not you know but
he's it's time to go out solo those guys
I mean everybody's probably losing a lot
of money now because of this you know
bands bands make money touring man it's
very tough so if you go to
patreon.com/scishow and sings I mean
he's doing music about this show so
you'll probably like it if you're a fan
of the show you're a fan of the show
you'll like what he's about he's got a
great voice he plays you know he plays
an instrument his website Nate Bergman
sings comments through Wix when we had
Wix as a sponsor [ __ ] Wix now but thank
you for doing that dad Nate Instagram
Nate Bergman sings go follow him
twitter.com Nate Bergman sings so go
show him support he's clearly a fan of
the show he really sings he really plays
music I respect that
I appreciate that he's no joke you know
he's just not you know he doesn't love
the cat those your cat that's okay I
think he should try to collab with the
cat you know I get it good for him you
know I support anyone in the arts I mean
you know not not really but I think it's
a nice thing to say even if not to do um
Nate Bergman ber GMA and Nate Bergman
sings calm patreon.com slash Nate
Bergman sings for just $5 a month
it features exclusive studio songs live
streams and playlist companions that are
uploaded every week it's probably a good
idea if you want to be a musician this
guy might like to live streams and play
you know why don't you teach people a
little guitar on there you know it's an
idea Nate
why do you throw a little guitar
tutorial in there teach people about
music a little bit battle that might get
them over it's a good idea it's a good
idea I'm full of good ideas left BMG
records after a major label failed to
launch a previous band and is releasing
music exclusively through patreon Wow
Wow
pretty cool this advertisement was paid
for with the current stimulus check in
several weeks unemployment good we
appreciate that and we're going to send
some people your way but I think you got
to teach them a little guitar on there
or whatever you do teach them a little
tutorial tell them about the music
business tell them what they got to do
to succeed tell them the good the bad
the ugly get you know get in there
really create a community of people that
want to be musicians I don't want them
I'm kidding I don't have anything that
you know I've none offer them but I mean
this guy is really committed to to doing
this so it's patreon.com slash Nate
Bergman sings Instagram at Nate na te
Bergman BER GMA n sings same on Twitter
go give him a follow if you like what
you see go over to that patreon he's
seeing for five dollars a month
he's literally singing for his supper
and then about that song mill at the end
we will have an attorney contact him and
we will threaten him and we will suit no
I'm kidding you have my blessing you can
do all of the make a who took Johnny
themed album whatever you want to do we
appreciate it we like that you are a fan
of the show and the life of the American
entertainer living on the line
interesting
wonder what that songs about the life of
the American entertainer living on the
line everything is a screen shot a
screen shot frozen in time they can
reimburse whenever screen shots suck oh
Jesus
Nate Birdman sinks that was made by the
way just pump through my nate has a
sing-along with Louis Farrakhan on his
patreon if you want to go check that out
he teaches Louis Farrakhan how to play
guitar I didn't know that I think that's
kind of cool he says I enjoy playing
music but I enjoy playing music the most
when I do it with Louis Farrakhan okay
it's interesting but that's fair me and
Louis started jamming and we really
respect each other's styles so if you
want exclusive content from Nate and
Louis Farrakhan go to his patreon they
play classical gasp yeah the song Nate
Bergman of lyin eyes what happened to
lionize that's the question the major
label failed to launch the previous band
so what does that mean you just went
solo gotcha
BMG records they [ __ ] him over it
looks like it's crazy
what's awkward is that our next ad is
for BMG records that's kind of awkward
but what are you gonna do patreon.com
Nate Bergman sings he's a talented man
he's now on his own if you love those
your cat you might not love this but you
know what I think he's wrong there I
think there's room for Birdman and does
your cat you know I think there's room
for everybody
nate louis farrakhan and does your cat
that's a collab those your cat in lose
Farrakhan collaborated show this man
some love audience go and follow him and
go and do whatever you know do whatever
feels right support the man he spent
money on the ad we appreciate that
we love independent creators artists
musicians whatever and we need them in
this country you know we need them we
also appreciate the cat but you know
we're all over the place here so patreon
calm mate Bergman sings Nate Bergman
sings on everything Twitter Instagram
Nate Bergman sings calm keep up with
them and we wish him the best
Hajin created a refreshing electrolyte
packed drink mix that me mix directly
into your water efficiently and
effectively hydrated the body each rapid
hydration mixes for central electrolytes
your body needs sodium potassium
magnesium and zinc kicked the coffee
folks kicked the caffeine it dehydrates
you and you crash this precise plenty of
electrolytes found in their mix helps
your body hydrated quickly and stay
hydrated all day Hodge it is backed by
research the formula was developed by an
Oxford scientist to provide perfectly
balanced efficient hydration there's no
synthetic colours TVR artificial
sweeteners the formula is vegan and you
can choose between three different
flavors or a variety pack hydrogen
starts it's just under a buck a packet
for 30 day supply you save even more
with a monthly subscription this
is great a lot of people are using and
I'm using it it's a great way to boost
yourself in the morning naturally
quickly you don't have to drink a
Frappuccino you don't have to have a
glass of cold brew you don't have to
[ __ ] have a 5-hour energy you don't
have to chew on a [ __ ] everything
here is a refreshing electrolyte packed
drink mix it's easy okay and let's be
honest if you like to booze it up this
is what you drink in the morning if you
have a couple of cocktails you drink
this you're good to go it's not
alcoholism you're just fun
so Hydra don't get you going so you
could stare at your kids and wife and go
alright alright alright daddy's feeling
good now go to drink hydrant calm slash
Tim D RI NK hydr a and T hydrant drink
hydrant calm slash Tim you're gonna love
it
it helps the show it helps you it helps
America it's what's needed do it now
Family Guy star Mike Henry will no
longer play Cleveland Brown how do you
made the announcement Friday on Twitter
it's been an honor to play Cleveland
Family Guy for 20 years I love this
character but persons of color should by
the way how regressive does that sound
I love these character but persons of
color pursues a color should get their
chance into role pursing to color that's
like this is a little incense is all
from today are they gonna see this on
the show yeah yeah yeah
Netflix pulls community episode over
blackface gets its kenji on it looks
great Duke ng on can't Asians do
blackface what are the rules Ken Jong's
like four feet tall well they do in
China right I think they do I'm doing a
blackface tour in China later this year
III antenna I as as a backup Liz oh I
make a lot of money doing that in China
I just they just play one of her songs
and I just
blame it on and I just put blackface on
I go and I got a two black leg that's
the real rough one they gotta put my
thigh in it all and I just go blaming on
the juice you can blame it on the juice
and I'm sick juice not choose but who
knows what that song really means I mean
do ten giong in black like if I don't
wedding that would be my wedding
invitation with Ken Jeong in blackface I
mean this is it's literally crazy saying
but here's the thing it doesn't look
like a black person I know how to get
this off please get us taken down off
YouTube you'll leave that up there for
too long so the guy who played Cleveland
is just gonna dip after 20 years it
looks like there's a purge right now 30
rock took down episodes with blackface
and other shows how much the question is
just an aside how much blackface was
going on Sarah Silverman did one in 2008
I know it's weird it's like I didn't
realize there was a lot of blackface
going on yeah I didn't realize how much
blackface was happening there like the
view is taking down an episode where all
the ladies to blackface I'm Barbara
Walters and today I'm in blackface to
honor the great Harriet Tubman yeah yeah
I mean was this just happening
everywhere this everybody do blackface
in this country I just wasn't aware of
it just Lane Maxwell being canceled over
blackface photo next on Access Hollywood
Jeffrey Epstein some interest is asking
the country for forgiveness because she
went is a point she went as Diana Ross
one Halloween but do you understand what
I mean folks were just kind of losing
our minds here about this and I know I'm
a white guy and that's easy for me to
say you know but I am Irish and there is
no group of people in this country they
suffered more than the Irish nobody
nobody our lives our other tragedy no
matter would no matter who you know I
mean the Irish we are a damned race this
little Marxist on Twitter always says
that Sean McCarthy who's uh she's sweet
kid he's not he's sweet kid
he doesn't think anyone should have more
than 5,000
but I like him he's like this little guy
could sunken and I was funny he's very
funny
he's very funny on Twitter and a nice
like a genuinely nice guy like a
sweetheart he's got a pretty wife like
he's like a good person um but he always
talked about that like he'll he's one of
these guys who understands like the
Irish Shiva last name like McCarthy
people expect you to be a loser Dylan I
can hide cuz it's French Dylan has a
little friendship but if your last names
like Oh Lachlan Oh Oh flare 'ti imagine
going through the world with the name
clarity yeah like you know go to Irish
last names
how sad people's lives are with an Irish
last name its eyes I would argue I would
argue that if your name is O'Sullivan
it's almost it's almost as bad as having
having been asleep
let's see Irish last names Kelly Byrne
RINO saw the the O's the bad ones like
oh oh Lachlan
these are the boys here we are here's
some Irish last names top ones are
Murphy Kelly keep going down O'Sullivan
Walsh myth O'Brien burn O'Connor O'Neill
O'Reilly Doyle toil hello my name is
patty Doyle yeah you're gonna fail
Gallagher Gallagher oof
this is worse keep going
McLaughlin John McLaughlin O'Carroll
nobody nobody who the name Oh Carol is
doing well you know about my friend
Bobby Oh Carol his wife lit him on fire
while they slept she said a banshee told
her to do it
Boyle Oh
Boyle the last name is boiled this is
these people power I've never heard that
I've never heard an Irish president be
power
I know Cavanaugh is Irish Cavanaugh
Brett Kavanaugh see you will not succeed
with a name like Cavanaugh never named
like Cavanaugh what are you gonna do you
know Brett Kavanaugh he's yeah yeah okay
so he's on the Supreme Court I bet he
couldn't be the president Higgins
Higgins when I thought I liked girls had
a crush on a girl whose last name is
Higgins she's I bet she has a horrible
life now horrible horrible life horrible
it's a horrible life Chris you know
Candice right I mean all we're trying to
do folks we gotta bring some enjoyment
back everything's too tight that's what
I was going to be silly this whole show
Chyna's going to fight us they're
probably going to win maybe not but if
we keep being [ __ ] losers about
everything like literally everything
it's gonna be a problem you know toughen
up a little
fetishizing trauma the word trauma
lightly traumas something serious trauma
should be reserved for genuine victims
of rape and sexual assault and soldiers
who've we've asked to kill children for
no reason that those people should have
trauma okay
like not people that want to hurt
something offensive or saw something
they didn't like they're like I have the
trauma the trauma stays with me out
traumas for soldiers decided for the
military because they think they're
doing the right thing and then they end
up in Afghanistan protecting pedophile
warlords that's who the word trauma is
for okay that's somebody who goes to an
open mic and here's something they don't
like am i right who's gonna play
Cleveland now no one knows being reims
is you think VIN right but Cleveland's
like a white black guy right kind it's
like a whiny suburban guy I'm not saying
black guys can't be whining suburban but
like we don't think of them as that
should we should we start thinking of
black guys like [ __ ] is that I mean I
know these the argument is like oh okay
but I don't think of black people as
criminals either you know like people
like oh you think you're scared of them
you think of them as criminals I was
like nah no I just don't think they're
[ __ ] so I don't think of them as like
wow wow wow wow like that's what
Cleveland is right Wow
I guess maybe that's what everybody want
you know um like Cleveland is the white
voice the black comedians do you know
right
that's what Cleveland always was so I
was like that's why the characters funny
he's like just big loaf of bread
Cleveland you know like he's not what do
we get have a thug Cleveland like a guys
like Moe [ __ ] I'm Cleveland like what
you know are we missing the point of
Cleveland a little bit he was like a fat
white [ __ ]
he's talking about cuz I took a suburban
male with tents should be like [ __ ]
voice by a white guy yeah some just some
lactating old white male
I just got milky titties he's driving a
Home Depot that he goes through the
[ __ ] drive-through us somewhere just
left that a little fart and just eat
something that's what we think of
Cleveland you don't think I like a cool
black dude right we don't think of
anyone who says any even if [ __ ] like we
don't think of like like Peter Griffin
Cleveland's like a guy that hang out
with Peter Griffin right look fat
suburban losers and quagmire who's a
rapist
yeah crime quagmire the rapist sig not
what are we fighting over make more
opportunities for black people make
better shows black people don't watch a
lot of your [ __ ] cuz it's wack yeah it's
wack it sucks a lot of my black friends
don't [ __ ] with this [ __ ] cuz it's bad I
don't mean Family Guy but I mean a lot
of the stuff that woke [ __ ] people
nobody watched a nightly show no one
watched it of any race watch the nightly
show so it wasn't good it was not good
was that Larry Whitmore Wilmore Wilmore
sorry don't erase him by saying Whitmore
I'm just saying we've lost our mind a
little bit here folks we're starting
it's starting to get it starting to feel
weird starting to feel very strange in
the sense that it's nothing's enough for
anybody I don't know what the future is
people like why people can't write roles
for black people now like right white
people can't write a character for a
black I mean like what are we doing are
we going back to the separate water
fountains Luscombe has made a point
today it's like at what point do we just
this seems like we're bringing back
segregation it seems like that white
fertility book we're written by a white
woman by the way I mean that if you read
any of that the dance they want you to
do when you meet someone so that you
don't offend them it's like no one will
ever be friends again right show him a
cause he by the way who I like on
Twitter follow him by the way get his
handle up he thinks it is kind of
interesting that identity politics is
the CIA's way of preventing any class
cohesion that's not it
Shawn no I don't know find him okay and
and he might have a point there like
he's like maybe all these big businesses
and you know you know intelligence you
know you know agencies and stuff keep
pushing this kind of radical identity
politics because it prevents any unity
amongst a class of people okay so that's
what he said like he's like this he has
a podcast called grub stalkers pod I
don't know what that's about they just I
don't know they give billionaires of
lashing or something but he's a funny
guy but he's he had a good point about
that where it's like the ruling class is
kind of served by continually dividing
people and it seems weird to kind of
like divide them my desk I don't know
then he says other wacky stuff like
nobody could have more than five hundred
thousand dollars Sean stop it
you're out of your mind
so follow that guy like him you won't
agree with everything he says but he's
very funny get my Twitter up follow me
too
by the way follow me on Twitter many of
you don't and it's unfortunate we're
changing the name of the cancel your
family tour I think we're gonna call it
life in the big city tour cancel your
family just seems a little tone deaf now
with Corona I don't know it also feels
like it's over
Dick Cheney says to wear a mask and I
listen to Dick Cheney why because Dick
Cheney pulled off 9/11 right Donald
Trump can't even [ __ ] pull off a wall
this guy soldered 3000 people on our own
soil
that's [ __ ] impressive and he says
we're masks I'm listening to him I'm
listening to a guy that killed 3,000 of
our own people I'm sorry I am okay yeah
he doesn't need to be a medical expert
I'm listening to a guy that instituted a
torture program and and and and and got
us out of that [ __ ] Geneva Convention
it says we shouldn't torture people
this guy tortured innocent people and he
killed them and that's who I listen to
guys who kill us and kill innocent
people and invade countries for no
reason really and and make a lot of
money for Halliburton and other defense
contractors and if he says wear a mask I
listen to him I listen to a guy who
spends most of the day torturing people
and a little part of the day being nice
to his lesbian daughter which is a nice
thing that he does that but I listen to
that guy I support that guy so if you're
not wearing a mask right now you're
making Dick Cheney unhappy and I don't
want to live in a country where you
ungrateful for are you dead
did he kill you did he torture you I
seem to remember the economy doing
pretty well after 9/11 thank you sir
thank you Dick Cheney so when a genocide
or mass murderer who Institute's torture
wears a mask and a cowboy hat
I listen when a genocide Oh monster who
is responding now this is this is what I
realize my career that like this this
rant right now is limits me this is
limiting right this is limiting you know
what I mean like I feel like I feel like
that like certain like this isn't like
Ellen who doesn't want this you know
what I mean Ellen doesn't want this
Ellen wants to hang out with Dick Cheney
Ellen wants to go to Abu Ghraib and see
where the blood got spilled and that's
why she makes 80 million dollars a year
and I'm very grateful for my patreon
thank you for that but I'll never make
that kind of money because what I
respect about Ellen is Ellen wants to
smell the burning flesh you see so she
wouldn't she wouldn't go on a rant like
this because there you know she would
she'd meet Dick Cheney somewhere you
know who knows Ellen's probably at
Bohemian Grove like leading that
cremation of care ceremony yeah she's
Ellen and she's like dancing and all
these billionaire CEOs are dancing their
world tech talking Dick Cheney's
tick-tocking in front of the owl in
front of the owl in front of Moloch
they're just playing the plains going
into the buildings and they're all just
[ __ ] like remember 2001 everybody's
got masks on they're watching the planes
go out of the buildings Ellen's just
[ __ ] there in front of the owl she's
[ __ ] doing the Charleston everybody's
there all the big CEOs the big media
heads they're all there Anderson
Cooper's there Cheney's pissin in his
mouth you know Don lemons there
everybody's having fun you know
imagine if I like financially my career
gets better I'm on CNN with a manager
Cooper interviews Maine is like hey I'm
like hey cuz I will have to do like I
will I will have to meet some of these
people eventually like on a show when
they interview me and I'm like how are
you how's it been uh Timmy meant to me
Fallon no no how are you how are you how
are you I don't think I meet him but I
might I'm just in an area that like I
could meet him I'm not expecting to I'm
not gonna like hang out with him I'm not
in that rarefied air of comedians it's
up there but like I could be in a place
where he might be and they're like there
could be like just this awkward I don't
think he knows who I am hopefully but
that that Clips almost got a million
views of me saying he bit someone's tit
that's funny though
so all I'm trying to say this is how me
in any episode Jenny slate needs to go
to jail
Dick Cheney does not okay old Dick
Cheney did was lice into a couple of
wars pull off a false flag to get us
into them Institute torture bankrupt our
country and and use it to kill innocent
people both at home and abroad Jenny
slate erased a black person using a
cartoon she's sick [ __ ] you know what I
mean
so I think she could go to jail and the
only way that she can redeem herself the
only way that Jenny slate can redeem
herself is if she can do Cleveland
Browns voice and if she can't do
Cleveland Browns voice that I've had
enough and she goes to the gulag but is
that a funny or tweet if I say should I
tweet Jenny slate Congrats EJ said uh
Nana job voicing Cleveland Brown I'm so
ready to get out of this business and
move to the desert you have no idea I'm
a year
away from Florida or the desert we I
don't know but I'm so close to just
pulling the [ __ ] chain get the [ __ ]
out of here I don't care anymore [ __ ]
meetings with people so what about what
about like what about what about what
about what about what about like hey hey
it's Josh it's Josh you chill hey hey
it's like what about what about the show
it's like you like what about what about
have you ever thought of like have you
considered you know it would be really
good like I really see you in hey shut
up shut up you go get me a show I'm
gonna get Rosie and Arnold on it to talk
about Q first [ __ ] episode first
episode if I have a [ __ ] show first
episode everybody's gonna have the
script to like we're ready to shoot and
then I go throw the script away boys and
then I bring Rosie and Arnold on I sit
her down i light her a cigarette and I
say challenge to truth Rose tell us the
truth see everybody being like
everybody's like paranoid reservation at
a restaurant Beverly Hills in half an
hour okay
I like ocean prime in Beverly Hills cuz
it's a it's a it's a it's a it's an
expensive Red Lobster and it's very
diverse black people of exhale of
seafood I love seafood and shellfish
that's why I go most most restaurants in
Beverly Hills are very white and Persian
but I like ocean promises like a big Red
Lobster mhm
that's my commitment to diversity I used
to eat there with LaToya Jackson all the
time she was in another table I'd be in
another chain you know I don't know
folks how great would that be just to
show first episode I just bring Roseanne
on did you can you play the Roseanne
Donald Trump but did you see what she
did recently oh I think so yeah he's a
[ __ ] genius I'm supposed to be on a
show can her [ __ ] son please get in
contact with me cuz your [ __ ] mother
is literally the one of the last [ __ ]
OGIS left in this [ __ ] game I don't
care what she believes it I'll find it
did she everyone deletes their tweets
now I don't know she somebody might have
[ __ ] told her to delete it she's so
good everything she does is good
is it you know what I think you know
discuss amongst yourselves if you don't
agree you don't really have to burn me
at the stake for just before not agree
with me but let me just throw out one
idea and I hope that the hungry dogs in
the street have enough meat as not to
come after me for thinking and speaking
I'm told of it a lot so much I have this
to say as follows and it's okay I said
cuz nobody lives have [ __ ] thing I
say we're just great I'm tired of being
monitored you know in correct deadly
[ __ ] [ __ ] it we say what I'm gonna say
Trump hear me when I say this Trump is
in my opinion the first woman president
of the United States the woman is just
[ __ ] she's designed to make me happy
everything she does not the monkey thing
she said but most of what she says
Planet of the Apes whatever but a lot of
what she says I just I just enjoy her
gosh darn it I just enjoy a crazy person
can't we go back to enjoying crazy
people can't comedians stop [ __ ]
going to college and telling everybody
how to live stop no one cares
we should not allow any comedians other
than like Mulaney we shouldn't allow any
comedians that went to college I mean I
it's ridiculous I know but I know it's
stupid but not the ones now the ones
graduating now are no good yeah I'm just
saying that we have to have fun people
out there are not having enough fun you
could enjoy the quesadilla it is quite
literally your last
enjoy and have fun have fun at the
Cheesecake Factory
oh and have fun go drink and get behind
the wheel of your car and drive because
it's fun
cheat on your significant other leave
your family and let them fend for
themselves because it's time for you
it's time for you now you understand
that it's not time for everyone else how
long have you lived for other people too
long but now in end times with many many
plagues
oh just enjoy enjoy what you have you
know enjoy what you have I'll tell you
that I want to show I want to shine I
want the industry to believe in me i III
want to be like Sarah Cooper I want I
want I want the people I want the people
with the suits in the offices to care I
want them to give me a shot because I
will I will make a beautiful show I will
make a beautiful show and the show will
end with Roseanne Arnold first of all a
black hand will go out to grab Jenny
slate and and forgive her and then Jenny
slate will see as the black hand toss
her closer that it's Candace Owens and
then and by the time Jenny's on the
other side of the of the of the stage
Roseanne peeks out and hands Jenny slate
cigarette I don't know if Jenny smokes
but she wears hey guys here you go and
then Jenny lights up a cigarette and
then they all just stand there and then
they hold up cue letter Q and then I
come out with dick cheney's and a child
he mercilessly tortured an Allen
DeGeneres and we
it's like everyone is watching good luck
out there Fox and have fun